buonasera a tutti
io non mi presenterei oltre quello che è
stato detto sono qui per parlare di
altro e vi vorrei parlare di una cosa
che mi è successa da poco mi è successo
che mia moglie siccome sa che mi
piacciono i mango ha comprato di mango e
quindi io stavo a casa con questi mango
in cucina da solo a me piacciono tanto
quindi l'ho aperto
adesso mi prendo dieci minuti per me ci
sono sbocciati il mango
non so se avete presente il sapore del
mango un po come la nostra pesca più
dolce più rotondo non molto su cosa
mangiamo questo mango e mi sono detto
stereo ma ti rendi conto che l'acqua che
centro questo mango è piovuta in una
foresta tropicale è finita dentro il
mango alle radici dell'albero e ti hanno
portato acqua in cucina a casa e lì era
partito il 30 pieno trip non c'era più
modo di fermarmi e quindi io mi trovo in
questa foresta tropicale col mio mango e
dico no per aspetta non è solo qui
l'acqua che sta dentro questo mango a 3
miliardi di anni si è formato a 3
miliardi di anni fa ha fatto tutti i
suoi giri in cielo nelle rocce negli
alberi eccetera e allora il mango alla
mia cucina ma che dico eh sì però mica
solo l'acqua e mango la roba di cui sono
fatto io la materia che fa il mio corpo
per quanto ne sappiamo dell'origine
l'universo c a 10 miliardi di anni
cioè io sono una cosa che viene da 10
miliardi di anni fa e ha viaggiato
decine di migliaia di anni luce è anni
luce e tanta roba
adesso a scuola non è che ci soffermiamo
tanto su questa cosa ma se ci pensate
la luce in un secondo fa otto volte il
giro della terra in un anno
immaginate la distanza decine di
migliaia di anni luce
la materia di cui sono fatto io viene da
così lontano
arrigo perché miseria qui la cosa si fa
interessante
trip è nel suo pieno carico senza
arrivare a queste cifre stratosferiche
che poi non riesci nemmeno a capire di
che cosa stavi parlando sono aiuto era
da cai marci
e lui si dice ogni respiro ad ogni
respiro
accogliamo nel corpo 10 triliardi di
atomi e per l'incessante movimento dei
venti in un solo anno abbiamo relazioni
intime con molecole di ossigeno e
ispirate da ogni persona in vita e anche
da chiunque sia mai vissuto
e questa roba interessante in un anno
sarà di go go
io respiro aria che ha respirato
napoleone respiro significa che entra
nel mio corpo mi trasmette una parte se
rimane fisicamente in me ma in me che
significa chi sono io è qui la cosa si
fa ancora più interessante questa scuola
a me non me l'hanno insegnato io spero
che oggi lo insegnano noi in realtà
siamo un ecosistema la parola e
microbioma noi siamo fatti da centinaia
di trilioni di organismi in realtà il 99
per cento dei geni unici nel nostro
corpo e di batteri senza di loro
noi non possiamo fare praticamente nulla
non possiamo digerire regolano il
metabolismo insegnano al nostro sistema
immunitario come funzionare influenza
nei nostri stati psicologici e difficile
parlare in termini di loro perchè loro
in realtà sono io senza di loro io non
esisto
io sono un ecosistema e qui vuoi capire
che quando dico trip intendo proprio 33
vero è la realtà e non siamo abituati a
pensare in questi termini pensare in
questi termini mi ha cambiato molto in
questi giorni quando la fortuna di avere
delle bellissime conversazioni con ora
betsson e ho preso questa sua citazione
le dice noi
l'acquario interno di trilioni di
creature il mio linguaggio la mia
cultura
il mio amore le mie idee la mia famiglia
la mia nazione e la mia colazione siamo
e non siamo separabili dalla particolare
versione di una persona che è me quindi
non è solo un problema una questione
fisica anche a livello di relazioni di
idee e di passioni noi non siamo da soli
non esistiamo
al che dico vabbè serio però torniamo un
attimo alla sanità mentale è vero che
noi abbiamo questo questa connessione
reale con tutto non esistiamo separati
no però nella realtà delle separazioni
esistono dei confini esistono tu guardi
la terra il mare quello un confine
adesso ditemi quello che vi pare
sopra c'è terra sotto c'è mare e beh in
realtà no perché se vai a guardare il
confine è soltanto un cambio netto dei
pattern nella realtà le cose cambiano in
modo molto concentrato nel tempo nello
spazio e a noi sembra un confine
in realtà al confine succedono le cose
più interessanti
questo è il confine tra la terra e il
mare è un ecosistema dentro l'ecosistema
e lo puoi fare per qualunque confine
persino per la morte
la verità è che i confini non esistono
semplicemente da una prospettiva di
skull ampia vediamo una variazione netta
e ci sembra un confine ma se guardi bene
il confine non c'è io avevamo il mare
quindi il mio corpo è cresciuto
nell'acqua del mare
adesso io so che quando metto la mia
mano nell'acqua
c'è uno scambio su una comunicazione con
migliaia di organismi questo confine del
mio corpo sapevo non essere così netto
se pure tu dove finisce la tua mano lo
vedi no
però appunto è un po sfumato poi mi è
successa una cosa
cinque mesi fa ha avuto un figlio e
anche oggi dire dove finisce il mio
corpo inizia il suo è veramente
difficile
veramente difficile quindi persino il
confine mi sembrava più naturale ovvio
in realtà non esiste e io mi ritrovo con
il mio mango in cucina ma perchè vi sto
dicendo tutto ciò vi sto dicendo tutto
ciò perché so di persone che sono in
questa stanza e chissà di quante non so
che si svegliano la mattina perché
vogliono migliorare il mondo vogliono
migliorare la loro famiglia vogliono
migliorare la loro città il loro paese
leggo sistema mondiale tutto e si
affaticano tanto a cercare di farlo ce
la mettono tutta
si alzano che entusiasmo io sono uno di
questi però poi le cose non cambiano
io mi trovo avere conversazioni con
persone sfiduciate che dicono tanto le
cose non cambiano
ora il punto è che le cose non cambiano
perché noi le approcciamo nel modo
sbagliato noi le approcciamo da un punto
di vista e gotico individuale noi
abbiamo la presunzione di sapere come
dovrebbe essere il mondo e questa
definisce il nostro concetto di
migliorarlo però non è tutta colpa
nostra
c'è stato un secolo della storia
dell'umanità il xvii secolo in cui
l'umanità aveva bisogno di certezze e ne
ha trovate tante e il secolo e la
rivoluzione scientifica che poi
rivoluzione ne possiamo parlare se lo è
stato comunque il seguito che abbia il
secolo che ha avviato la rivoluzione
industriale e il secolo che ci permette
oggi di volare sugli aerei di avere dei
telefonini ho fatto tante belle cose nel
fare queste tante belle cose però in
particolare dall'europa perché ho
esternato in europa stiamo parlando del
secolo di cartesio galileo newton
keplero tanta roba
tanta roba tutta insieme nel fare questo
ha creato al nostro pensiero
due grandi problemi che oggi ci
riportiamo e che poi ci hanno fatto
creare delle istituzioni basate su
questi problemi
il primo problema
va sotto il nome di riduzionismo ora
cartesio era bravissimo in questo cos'è
il riduzionismo in sintesi è l'idea che
per capire una cosa grande
la dico prima nel modo più semplice in
cui riesco a dirla la dobbiamo spezzare
in cose più piccole e capendo le cose
più piccole tutti i pezzi
alla fine avremmo capito l'intero il
mondo non funziona così
o quantomeno il mondo funziona così in
torni in contesti molto specifici in
parti molto piccole della realtà piccole
nel tempo nello spazio
in generale i sistemi complessi non
funzionano così ci sono delle proprietà
emergenti che esistono in virtù del
fatto che le parti sono insieme per
dirla banalmente se prendete tutti gli
organi di una persona e li mettano
insieme non fate una persona ci sono a
parte il fatto che doveva essere
frankestein a farla vivere ma al netto
di questo ci sono delle cose che fanno
la persona per quello che è che non
capirete mai capendone le parti solo le
relazioni e non solo le relazioni
all'interno le persone le relazioni tra
le persone con testi che pensare che io
possa descrivere un anatra così e poi
guardare la realtà e capire che queste
anatre non sono più da soli in questa in
questa foto stiamo avendo un volo di
uccelli non è la stessa cosa di capire
la singola anatra peraltro se capiamo
gli organi della tra non avremmo capito
manco lei e queste anatre se fossero
altrove sarebbero è un'altra cosa
invece sono in relazione con l'acqua col
vento con quello che c'è intorno
ok cercare di capire le cose o quanto
meno di ascoltare le cose di vivere le
cose nella loro molteplicità di
relazione e qualcosa che non siamo
abituati a fare siamo abituati a
scomporre in pezzi e pensare che lì ci
sia l'essenza delle cose
questo è il primo problema se volete un
esempio molto bello cercate su youtube
questo video è un video potete cercare
lupi yellowstone fiumi un video di pochi
minuti
e vi racconta quanto le cose in realtà
siano interconnesse quindi non
comprensibili nel loro essere sole
in sintesi rintroducendo dopo uno
squilibrio del parco di yellowstone
rintroducendo un branco di lupi si sono
visti degli effetti abbastanza
come dire attendibili per esempio sono
diminuiti cervi cervi quindi hanno
mangiato di meno e erbe eccetera
eccetera
però poi sono successe delle cose che
sembrano strane aver introdotto i lupi
ha cambiato il corso dei fiumi
l'interconnessione dalle cose ha degli
effetti che appunto sono emergenti e che
non possiamo prevedere prima se capiamo
che dobbiamo osservare nella relazione
allora iniziamo a capire qualcosa di più
del mondo che vogliamo migliorare questo
vale anche per le persone einstein
scritto questa frase bellissima tra
l'altro continua è il seguito è anche
molto bello un essere umano è parte del
tutto la sua esperienza di sé dei suoi
pensieri e sentimenti come fossero
separati dal resto è una sorta di
illusione ottica della sua coscienza
quindi riduzionismo separazione tra le
cose è un'idea non è la realtà seconda
meccanicismo meccanicismo come lo
vogliamo dire in sintesi lo vogliamo
dire pensando che il mondo sia come un
orologio svizzero
quindi che tecnica ente si e ci dica è
complicato cioè se io muovo una rotella
posso sapere con dalle proporzionalità
delle formule stranissime però comunque
posso sapere che cosa succederà a tutto
il resto dell'organismo in realtà
non è vero il mondo è lineare soltanto
ancora una volta in ambiti molto
specifici momenti molto limitati in
generale non è lineare in matematica si
dice e non lineare a cambiamenti molto
piccoli di condizioni possono conseguire
cambiamenti enormi dell'intero sistema
che e qui si inizia a parlare di sistemi
adattivi complessi il mondo non è così
pardon ma è così un sistema è così
un'azienda e così non è un non è un
organigramma un gruppo di persone
una città e così ognuno di questi sono
dei individui aziende player
ognuno di quei pallini quelle sono le
interazioni tutte queste interazioni
generano qualcosa che assolutamente non
lineare
il punto è che condizioni piccoline io
vado a toccare per fare reagire e fare
fiorire e fare risuonare questo sistema
se inizio a capire che la realtà non è
lineare ha voglia che pianifico su
diagrammi di gantt il mondo funzione non
altro modo
utilissimi per fare altro per capirci su
come è fatto un progetto non possiamo
far aderire la realtà a un nostro schema
dobbiamo capire che cosa emerge e
imparare a interpretarlo in tempo reale
questo è uno schema abbastanza teorico
matematico ma basta guardare qui vedete
esattamente la stessa cosa la quantità
di relazioni che c'è all'interno di
questa foto se pensate soltanto a quanti
insetti ci sono in quell'acqua e
infinita come si modifica una cosa del
genere non è per niente lineare come si
interagisce con questo come si ascolta
un una fabbrica una un tessuto di
relazioni del genere chiaramente questo
è ancor più vero per le persone
qui ci sono in questa foto ci sono
migliaia di famiglie rappresentate
migliaia di storie di problemi
una passione comune ma chissà da qua in
quanti modi diversi interpretata ogni
sistema umano e così la città di messina
è così l'italia è così la società tutta
oggi e così è un sistema complesso fatto
di parti tangibili ed i parti non
tangibili e questo ci riporta al mondo
che vogliamo cambiare nel quale si
realizza quello che gregory bateson
chiama un ecologia della mente
non c'è nulla che esiste nel mondo in
separazione nel meno nell intangibile
non esiste un'idea proprietaria
lasciamo perdere tutti i discorsi legali
legati a questo noi costruiamo
continuamente su relazioni e su
relazioni di relazioni attraverso
molteplici contesti io esisto nella mia
famiglia esistono nella mia azienda
prendo una idea di quale apporto di là
poi vado a parlare un altro paese sento
delle cose neanche me le ricordo le
porto altrove è un sistema emergente non
è lineare e non esistono cose separate
nel momento in cui iniziamo a capire
questo possiamo approcciarci come ci
abbracciamo allora noi abbiamo lavorato
tanto in project se come avete sentito
oggi è l'azienda in cui lavoro
siamo partiti da una cosa tanto semplice
quanto potente le storie le storie sono
qualcosa che da sempre noi utilizziamo
per raccontarci per contaminarci per
essere insieme da sempre rappresentiamo
con storie in mille modi
quello che per noi è importante quello
che vogliamo far sapere quello che
vogliamo rispondere e in un tessuto di
storie generiamo delle narrative una
narrativa è un fiume di storie per le
narrative sono morte persone per una
narrativa
sei pronto a superare la tua visione
individuale di te stesso
le narrative muovono la società le
narrative risuonano e attivano effetti
esponenziali propri dei sistemi
complessi risuonano si attiva una
risonanza nel sistema
adesso iniziamo a capire che cosa
possiamo fare se vogliamo migliorare un
contesto anche fosse la nostra famiglia
quali narrative in cosa mi inserisco
come risuona tra noi non per me o per te
quand'è che una cosa risuona quando
tocca la frequenza di chi siamo
tocca la nostra identità una cosa
risuona con me quando a qualcosa di
profondo in comune con chi io sono o
penso di essere allora noi siamo partiti
abbiamo tirato fuori degli strumenti in
cui ci lavoriamo questo strumento
interessante si chiama già il secondo
nome ora ecco fink in canvas serve per
aiutare un'organizzazione a capire come
può mettersi in un contesto non voglio
usare la parola strategia anche una
parola veramente viene alla guerra non
mi piace però come si vuole posizionare
qual è il suo sense making all'interno
di un mercato di un di un area
geografica in modo tale da potersi
vedere dal suo punto di vista e dal
punto di vista dell'ecosistema allo
stesso tempo nel fare questo lavoro
siamo partiti dall identità che al
centro poi ci sono altre cose ci sono i
punti di forza la contribuzione di
valore il lavoro le relazioni eccetera e
si arriva all'interfaccia con
l'ecosistema che da un lato la risonanza
dall'altro solo nella narrativa come
posso inserirmi in queste cose qui ora
la cosa interessante del lavoro che
stiamo facendo qui e che ci ha fatto
toccare con mano come una volta che tu
arrivi fuori e ti interfacci con le
narrative e sperimenti la risonanza e
l'ecosistema con te
questo cambia la tua identità e riparti
dal centro di nuovo è un respiro
continuo tra questi due punti di vista
continuo ogni cosa che fai nasce da te
ti ritorna dall'ecosistema e cambia chi
sei
questo è il modo in cui le cose
possono andare risonanza in un sistema
umano complesso possono funzionare e non
ci siamo inventati
niente di nuovo perché in africa esiste
una parola che è ubuntu da tempo
immemore che significa si può tradurre
in mille modi un bel linguaggio perché
non è troppo analitico direi comunque il
concetto di ubuntu e umanità intesa come
io sono perché noi siamo il mio essere
una persona un essere umano non è
separabile dal fatto che ci sono gli
altri intorno a me in natura una persona
sola
in realtà qualunque scrivente solo
ammesso che sia possibile ricordatevi il
mio trip di prima muore noi siamo solo
perché siamo in un contesto o in realtà
in più contesti allora questo ci inizia
a far capire le cose con una serenità
diversa
in realtà si potrebbe far sentire
impotente perché dice io sono nulla
in questo sistema cioè mi hai detto che
sono polvere di stelle mi hai detto che
respiro l'aria di napoleone mi hai detto
che devo trovare la rative che fanno
risuonare il mondo lasciamo perdere
in realtà quello che vi sto dicendo è
che siamo molto importanti non impotenti
il nostro essere nulla
allo stesso tempo significa essere tutto
e questo significa che ci viene naturale
se guardiamo le cose a questo punto di
vista andare verso quello che risuona
abbiamo sentito anche oggi è una cosa
che ci abbiamo dentro da milioni di anni
e più semplice ultima volta che vi
faccio vedere questo mondo
adesso è diverso adesso sappiamo che c'è
possibilità che non siamo ingabbiati in
una linearità che non esistono cose
separate ma che le cose possono
risuonare e noi possiamo farlo dobbiamo
ascoltare però per sapere quali sono le
narrative dobbiamo aprirci al capire
quello che c'è intorno e lasciare un
attimo da parte il nostro istinto di
dire questa città dovrebbe essere così
questa società dovrebbe essere così
ascoltiamo quello che c'è vediamo qual è
la possibilità che sta emergendo milan
kundera scritto nel insostenibile
leggerezza dell'essere
tutto ciò che accade necessariamente che
è già previsto che si ripete e muto
soltanto la possibilità ci parla e noi
leggiamo il suo messaggio come zingari
leggono le immagini lasciate nella tassa
dai fondi di caffè tutti i sistemi
complessi inclusa concluse le persone
hanno una profondità e hanno una
superficie
purtroppo normalmente noi abbiamo
accesso alla superficie tra la
superficie dice tanto quell'espressione
quell'emozione che affiora sul viso di
una persona
quanto ti dice di quello che c'è in
profondità quella storia che affiora da
un gruppo di persone mentre fanno una
pausa tra due meeting di lavoro quanto
ti dice quanto quello che vediamo sulla
superficie se lo impariamo a leggere ci
fa capire che cosa ci sta dicendo un
sistema fortemente interconnesso di cui
siamo parte il punto è imparare a
leggere la superficie vedere quali onde
si stanno formando che noi possiamo
decidere di ser fare insieme ad altri e
che poi creeranno altre onde lasciando
un attimo da parte questa idea del bio
come se fossimo separati e potessimo
cambiare una cosa sapendo che cosa
succederà dopo
questa è fantascienza
chiudo dicendo lo con una frase di una
cultura a me molto cara che la cultura
polinesiana che tra l'altro credo abbia
molto in comune col nostro mediterraneo
ma questa è un'altra
storia la frase di un maestro dell'arte
antica del wayfinding della navigazione
ed è tanto semplice da non poterla
dimenticare se sai leggere l'oceano non
ti smarrirà i mai ma ho poi lag
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]